so big announcements on new coved
restrictions yesterday
uh different leaders of different
nations have gone in different
directions
do you think boris johnson went far
enough there are obviously different
rules now in england scotland and wales
and
one of my criticisms of the prime
minister is that he hasn't held the four
nations
um together barely had meetings with the
leaders in
the devolved administrations and it
would be far better if there's one set
of rules across the whole of the united
kingdom what's your view on households
on households i mean we're supporting
the government's rule
of six obviously we'll have to keep it
under close review
but i am conscious of not trying to put
up a different set of propositions
to the government the furlough scheme
you want more support for people
if they can't get back to work as the
government is introducing new
health restrictions it's phasing out
economic
support businesses now as the result of
these new restrictions
are going to be put under huge strain
and you owe it to them to put a support
mechanism in place and the government
really should have done that yesterday
let's move on to your speech yesterday
um you talked about the prime minister's
character
in your speech you said of boris johnson
that while he was writing flippant
columns about blended bananas
i was defending victims and prosecuting
terrorists while he was being sacked by
a newspaper for making up quotes
i was fighting for justice and the rule
of law that their quite
personal attacks you didn't used to make
such
personal attacks and what's changed
boris johnson and i are very
two very different individuals and i
think
it's very important that people see and
understand that the labour party is
under new leadership it's for me to set
out how i will lead the labour party
that's what i was doing yesterday
you're playing the man not the ball i
mean you're criticizing him personally
rather than the policies aren't you
well character matters at a time like
this people looking to the prime
minister
um and they they absolutely need the
reassurance
that he and the government are able to
do what's necessary uh to ensure the
infection rate goes down and to do
what's necessary to avoid mass
unemployment so
at this time above all else character
matters but in your speech yesterday you
said
he's just not up to the job so you do
think he's a bad leader
the prime minister and the government
collectively um
are guilty in my view of serial
incompetence there have been 12 u-turns
now i'm
quite prepared to accept that uh a
government will
make mistakes in a pandemic like this
and one or two u-turns
are probably a sign of a government
listening and then changing but when
you've got
12 in a row the only conclusion is
serial incompetent
you've got a clear strategy when it
comes to boris johnson the conservatives
but what about the smp
you will never win an election if you
can't win
scotland and go back to labour's winners
not since 1955 you'll know this what i'm
about to say
has the labour party formed a government
with less than
40 seats in scotland how many seats do
you have in scotland now
well look i'll be perfectly open about
this
there's no route back for labor that
doesn't run through
scotland how many cities why i was in
scotland it was because
well we've got one and what do you offer
scottish people that might get you
another 39 seats
will you rule out an independence
referendum as boris johnson's done
clearly what i was discussing last week
in scotland with scottish labour was
the importance of rebuilding the economy
in scotland what's your position do you
rule out
another referendum in scotland we will
be making the argument going into that
election next may
that this is not the time for another
divisive independence referendum
do you see that there are other
priorities do you see this as we talked
about when it came to brexit as a matter
that should have been settled for a
generation not having another referendum
in scotland
well i'm simply saying that
another divisive referendum is i think
about the last thing
that we need in january you said if the
snp won a majority in the hollywood
election they would have
a mandate for that for a second
referendum
i accept this is a question for scotland
do you stand by that principle
i'm concentrating at the moment on the
argument that we need to make between
now next
may where i say the rather priority i
understand that but i'm asking you
not about the election in may i'm asking
you about the principle
an snp majority gives them a mandate for
a referendum
in january you said that you would
accept it's a question for scotland if
the s p
win that majority do you in principle
stand by what you say in january or do
you want to move away from that
well we're going into um an election in
may where we will all set out our
positions
the labour party position will be but
what happened
what you said in january what happens
beyond that is hypothetical and
um you're dodging the question
in politics people say with great
certainty what's going to happen who's
going to win what they're going to do
what's going to happen
what's going to happen i'm asking you
whether you stand by what you said in
january when you said
they would have a mandate for that well
these issues are questions
um for scotland i do stand by that
i'm setting out the argument that we the
labour party scottish labour
will be making between now next may